so here like are you feeling anything
now yes it's crazy when I look out into
the audience like all I see in here is
dead people like I feel like I'm
connecting it's like the movie $0.06
your that boat is like I feel like I'm
connecting with like the funeral home
because all these souls that are here
you know trying to speak and trying to
connect at first well your mom departed
your mom sitting right next to you can I
get up what what your mother's right
here the way that it works for me is
that when I'm in a room or I'm in and in
an area all of your soul so try to come
through and speak and she was just
sitting next to you and saying that's my
daughter that's my daughter so know what
your mom's way of just acknowledging
that you're here and letting you know
that she is okay this was a woman who
had suffered before her passing here in
the physical world because what happens
is Kelly's that they'll put me back in
their body to show me what had going on
and they'll stand next to to show that
they're here and she showed me she
couldn't breathe before she had passed
she's been on a ventilator I feel like
I'm what like I'm drowning what I'm
gonna watch she had a heart attack I was
in the emergency room she was 62 years
old your mom says to me that first of
all she wants to thank you for keeping a
promise to her she says you promise to
her that you weren't gonna leave her
side because she was afraid she says and
you know that my daughter stayed with me
all night long and you laid on the side
of her and you laid with her and your
mom just wants to say thank you so much
for allowing my soul to go the other
side yeah
she also says when I'm connecting with
her that you feel her all the time
because she shows me that she's in the
house with you and let you talk with her
and your mom says I hear everything that
you do Jesus so thank you for laying
with me staying with me and making my
journey to the other side okay
she said cuz I couldn't have done it
without you she says and thank you for
respecting my wishes I mean so wait you
can come over because I want to ask you
this cuz like you just brought up the
journey afterwards right so do a lot of
people ask you oh sorry oh wait she said
but wait do a lot of oh I'm so sorry oh
that's what a lot of people ask you like
what happens like after people pass like
after they die or I will I mean cuz if
you see them like what do you think
happens when we die so what happens is
is that when you first pass out excited
read for a lot of people and their love
to us will come through and tell me what
happens afterwards and when you first
pass out of when you first go the other
side you're immediately greeted by
family members that had past family
members pets people that had passed on
they're all the air it's literally like
one big family reunion on the other side
okay well thank you for that was
incredible and Hayami i am so glad i
don't see dead people though so please
dead people here in the room I can't
handle it okay just you know subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going